To me,
there's no question that the United
States,
as a matter of policy,
must be against torture with sign
treaties to that effect.
We brought people to trial
internationally because we accused them
of torture and some of the things the
Bush administration did fall into the
same category of tortures as the
Japanese.
We tried after World War II,
the legacy of the George W dot Bush
administration will be calamity,
calamity for our country here in America
and for the world.
For those eight years.
We went backwards almost the whole time.
So much damage was caused to the quality
of our government.
Good people left the government in
droves.
The executive branch was politicized by
people who,
uh,
when no,
nothings do nothings and they stopped
functioning and all the problems we had
here and abroad just festered and got
worse and got worse.
What a legacy.